iteration over perfection
[Music]
the first few days of this week I was
working on the design project another
thing that I learned or maybe rather
proved once again was that communication
is the key and crumbs are ready useful
when you work on their project whether
it's for design or for programming
iteration is the key and good product is
never done so based on your prototype
you conduct the user testing and later
you can implement solutions that will be
better better for your users its first
day yesterday i was taking part in
because come vita it was another coffee
and cold meeting where we were
discussing the challenges trying to 500
bucks and discuss that projects they're
working on we are doing the design
fatigue and covered you trying to find
better solutions for solving our
problems since the morn here is
colonizing another front and margarita
and we've just announced it would be
about be free and SVG today I was also
learning about state machine and I also
came back to frequent cam video
challenges pretty basic stuff pretty
useful to know it's Friday today I'm
working on the design section for my
portfolio I'm preparing the movies in
order to show my experience in the
design for the time being i can say that
exam and freshly oiled iterate on the
page in the future maybe change some
items in the portfolio later so my new
about page is finally live next week I'm
going to come back to the act and
learn more than the basics i also want
to finish the video challenges that i
started this week the video challenges
from flickr account the next week I'm
going also to revive my previous project
from the perspective of faith machine
keep on doing and see you next week
[Music]